season former university of new orleans  basketball walk-on and john  butler a native of biloxi mississippi is  now in his second  nba season glad you're with us wherever  you may be  grizzlies this is game three of a  four-game home stand they'll be  back-to-back  with brooklyn tomorrow cleveland is on  the second of a back-to-back  they lost at orlando last night 105-94  and we will delay the tip momentarily  as the players head to the sideline and  link arms in a show of solidarity  the thing is every team all games  yesterday games today  where these guys will show their  solidarity  show that they they will stand together  and continue their fight  for equal justice in this country  both coaches met with the referees  before the game to indicate what they  had  intended to do taylor jenkins getting  together with jb bickerstaff and the  three officials  social justice as i said to taylor  jenkins in our pregame chat top of mind  in the nba